[Musique]
depuis quelques jours devant le conseil
municipal de Rio où il siège c'est en
voiture blindée qu'arrive Chico à lengar
si le conseiller municipal est candidat
de gauche aux élections législatives
fédérales a pris de telles mesures de
sécurité c'est parce qu'il vient de
recevoir une menace de mort
je vais envoyer quelqu'un te tuer je
sais où tu habites c'est un patriote pro
bolsonaro pro-arm
et notre campagne s'oppose au port
d'armes
regardez il en a des qualités
il est très chrétien
sur son profil l'homme compare le
communisme qui menacerait le Brésil au
nazisme
vient de déposer plainte et a
rendez-vous ce jour-là avec le
secrétaire de la police civile pour
prendre des nouvelles de l'avancée de
l'enquête
ça m'inquiète beaucoup et on prend ses
menaces très au sérieux c'est pour ça
qu'on est très attentif à l'enquête de
police en cours pour qu'elle appréhende
le suspect rapidement elle a tout notre
soutien qu'on résolve cette enquête au
plus vite et qu'il n'y ait pas de
problème par la suite
est loin d'être le seul depuis quelques
semaines la campagne a pris une tournure
dramatique en juillet dernier en pleine
fête d'anniversaire un militant du Parti
des travailleurs a été tué par un
policier probolso Naro
salon
dont le nord du pays un homme à
poignardé à mort un électeur de Lula un
sympathisant de bolsonaro a lui aussi
était assassiné à coup de couteau des
meurtres politiques auxquels viennent
s'ajouter de nombreux éclats de violence
sur cette vidéo filmée dans le nord de
Rio il y a quelques jours des
échauffourés ont éclaté entre caen
opposés
certains muni d'armes à feu une femme
enceinte a perdu son bébé
si le candidat Chico à l’incarte dénonce
publiquement la menace qu'il subit
aujourd'hui c'est que l'heure est grave
selon lui
il y a une radicalisation sans précédent
l'adversaire politique est perçu comme
quelqu'un qui doit être éliminé la
situation empire au Brésil c'est grave
il n'y a qu'un camp qui est polarisé
dans cette campagne qui n'arrive pas à
admettre qu'il peut de fait perdre les
élections
le président de la République est
agressif et remet constamment en
question la légitimité du processus
électoral et du Tribunal Supérieur
électoral
en ligne de mire le président candidat à
ses récentes déclarations qui remettent
en question le vote électronique tout
comme sa communication agressive envers
les journalistes
mais le président se défend d'un site à
la violence
électorale de Lullin de protection que
le candidat de gauche participe à son
dernier grand meeting de campagne
autour de lui la sécurité a été
renforcée ces derniers jours
malgré la joie de ses sympathisants
l'ombre de la violence plane sur le
premier tour selon une dernière enquête
plus de 67% de la population a peur
d'être physiquement agressé en raison de
son choix politique
avant je mettais des autocollants sur ma
voiture sur mes vêtements j'affiche mon
vote sans crainte
pour Noël aujourd'hui je ne fais plus ça
parce qu'il n'est pas impossible d'être
agressé en marchant dans la rue ou bien
dans les lieux publics donc je n'affiche
pas ouvertement pour qui je vais voter
fidèle défenseur de l'ex-président
le sénateur rendolf Rodriguez a décidé
d'agir soutenu par une coalition de 9
parties il vient de demander au tribunal
supérieur électoral l'ouverture d'une
ligne téléphonique de dénonciation des
violences pendant les élections
le juge va interdire le port d'armes
entre ce vendredi à la veille de
l'élection et jusqu'au lundi d'après
le Brésil ne s'est jamais confronté aux
fascisme avec autant de force
qu'aujourd'hui mais
dans les pires années de la dictature
militaire la violence n'a jamais autant
été disséminée comme dans cette campagne
le tribunal supérieur électoral a
autorisé le déploiement des forces
armées dont plus de 500 municipalités
pour assurer l'exercice libre et
démocratique du vote au Brésil